how you doing good how are you zach good
to see you all right
doing great so you're no stranger to the
to the zombie film of course with dawn
of the dead in 2004 and i read that you
wrote the draft for army of the dead 10
years ago
yes actually i came up with a story at
least 10 years ago maybe longer and joby
harold wrote the script
and at that time for another director
so when the movie came back around you
know uh with netflix
i literally said you know what i'm not
even going to read the draft
i know the story and then i hired uh
shea hatten and i and we sat down and
just i said okay this is what i think
happens and i just banged it we banged
it out
so i kind of made it fresh again for
myself
how do you even go about adding another
layer to like the undead genre and what
sparked it for you
yeah it's true i mean i'm pretty i'm
pretty
clear on this zombie rules you know
you'd imagine that i i might have some
experience with the zombie rules um and
yeah so to to
to elevate it or to turn it up a notch i
think it's really just about
i was always trying to figure out what
was necessary for the for the movie like
what did i
need to have happen and um and one of
the things i wanted to have happen was
um the audience to generate to have some
sympathy for the zombies if it was
possible
that that's how i i was trying to get uh
you know
the audience to momentarily at least go
like oh
that's not cool um and so yeah and so
that was
that was part of the thing that was
motivating how we evolved them
mission accomplished because there was a
couple points where i'm like i don't
even know who i'm rooting for at this
moment because
it felt bad um so a couple things for
for easter egg
hunters here there's a snyder cut
reference
in the vault yes there is including this
and kind of where
you were when this scene was shot yeah
like at that point uh we included the
snyder cut
um canisters uh it was my idea to do of
course
cause i'm crazy uh but um
at that point there was no hope of uh or
there was no real
at all desire or inkling that there
might even be a snyder cut released
so it's funny to see that we did that um
returned from the movie to uh
you know this kind of uh
world where that was possible so
anything's possible i guess
it's gotta be really cool to watch it
now and be like oh my god that's in
there and
this came out yeah it's true
at that point that's exactly where the
movie the where the movie was locked in
a vault
i read that you're in the opening
sequence a couple times and that it was
like
unintentional i would love to yeah if
you look uh and there's some
there's a mirror uh that uh
at the qc you know we do this quality
check you know
every watch the movie hundreds of times
to look for like some weird little
mistakes and stuff
and i got a call they're like oh we
found you in
in this one shot and i was like oh yeah
that's right because i remembered it
and i said they were like wanted to
erase it and i was like oh no i'll leave
it it's fine
you know it's like uh nobody will notice
it so
i'm gonna like go back and like sift
through because i was trying to find it
i went back a couple times i was like i
can't find it so
it's like hidden in there i think that's
yes it's a few frames but i'll still
frame it and
take a screenshot my favorite sequence
had to be just like the opening
with the full vegas like seeing like
undead elvis and all that and i read in
a recent interview that you had to break
this down
you cut out a male stripper who had a a
huge bite taken out of his penis can you
please tell me about this yeah yeah i
had this i
i really wanted to like you know kind of
just go to the
the full the full uh the full monty
of vegas if you will um and uh
yeah so we included this bit but then
when i watched it the other you know it
was a while ago and i was like you know
maybe it's early in the movie for this
you know
you know for your for your average for
your average viewer i want them
you know to stay in but um yeah it was
fun
it was fun to shoot anyway it's clear
you had so much fun with this and you
seem to be very in control of where this
franchise is headed which is so great
and with the prequel and the animated
series already in motion
how many army of the dead projects do
you foresee is there anything you can
you can tell me yes well there is uh i
mean for sure
you know we're in the middle of making
uh an animated prequel
that is uh you know adult animation
whatever that is
um you know it's a very uh it's sort of
it it it dives into the zombie like
origins
um and we sort of get a sense of what's
going on there
um and then matthias uh
has shot already and um i've seen
and we're in we're in the process of
completing uh his
prequel deter story um
of this the safecrackers story is sort
of a romantic comedy heist film
it tells where he was before you know uh
scott
and cruz find him in the back of the
locksmith's shop
so um gwendolyn's locksmith shop
ironically you'll learn that that means
something
anyway uh and the gator damarang uh
is really an important plays an
important role in all of this
um so that was really fun to do and and
um
look if um there was ever a desire for
more
um army of the dead like shay and i know
exactly where
the story goes uh so yeah we're ready
you're awesome out of i'm out of time
but lovely talking to you oh great
talking to you thank you very much